Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This image is the result of a light simulation
program, created by research scientists.
It looks absolutely beautiful, but the light
simulation algorithm is only part of the recipe
here.
To create something like this, we also need
a good artist who can produce high-quality
geometry, lighting, and, of course, good,
life-like material models.
For instance, without the materials part,
we would see something like this.
Not very exciting, right?
Previously, we introduced a technique that
learns our preferences and helps filling these
scenes with materials.
This work can also generate variants of the
same materials as well.
In a later technique, we could even take a
sample image, completely destroy it in photoshop,
and our neural networks would find a photorealistic
material that matches these crazy ideas.
Links to both of these works are available
in the video description.
And, to improve these digital materials, this
new paper introduces something that the authors
call a multi-resolution neural material representation.
What is that?
Well, it is something that is able to put
amazingly complex material models in our light
transport programs, and not only that, but…oh
my.
Look at that!
We can even zoom in so far that we see the
snagged threads.
That is the magic of the multi-resolution
part of the technique.
The neural part means that the technique looks
at lots of measured material reflectance data,
this is what describes a real-world material,
and compresses this description down into
a representation that is manageable.
Okay…why?
Well, look.
Here is a reference material.
You see, these are absolutely beautiful, no
doubt, but are often prohibitively expensive
to store directly.
This new method introduces these neural materials
to approximate the real world materials, but
in a way that is super cheap to compute and
store.
So, our first question is, how do these neural
materials compare to these real, reference
materials?
What do you think?
How much worse a quality do we have to expect
to be able to use these in our rendering systems?
Well, you tell me, because you are already
looking at the new technique right now.
I quickly switched from the reference to the
result with new method already.
How cool is that?
Look.
This was the expensive reference material,
and this is fast neural material counterpart
for it.
So, how hard is this to pull off?
Well, let’s look at some more results side
by side.
Here is the reference.
And here are two techniques from one and two
years ago that try to approximate it.
And you see that if we zoom in real close,
these fine details are gone.
Do we have to live with that?
Or, maybe, can the new method do better?
Hold on to your papers, and let’s see.
Wow!
While it is not a 100% perfect, there is absolutely
no contest compared to the previous methods.
It outperforms them handily in every single
case of these complex materials I came across.
And when I say complex materials, I really
mean it.
Look at how beautifully it captures not only
the texture of this piece of embroidery, but,
when we move the light source around, oh wow!
Look at the area here around the vertical
black stripe and how its specular reflections
change with the lighting.
And note that none of these are real images,
all of them come from a computer program.
This is truly something else.
Loving it.
So, if it really works so well, where is the
catch?
Does it work only on cloth-like materials?
No-no, not in the slightest!
It also works really well on rocks, insulation
foam, even turtle shells and a variety of
other materials.
The paper contains a ton more examples than
we can showcase here, so make sure to have
a look in the video description.
I guess this means that it requires a huge
and expensive neural network to pull off,
right?
Well, let’s have a look.
Whoa, now that’s something.
It does not require a deep and heavy-duty
neural network, just 4 layers are enough.
And this, by today’s standard, is a lightweight
network that can take these expensive reference
materials and compress them down in a matter
of milliseconds.
And they almost look the same.
Materials into our computer simulations straight
from reality?
Yes please!
So, from now on, we will get cheaper and better
material models for animation movies, computer
games, and visualization applications!
Sign me up right now!
What a time to
be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!